[Musique]
maintenant nous sommes en fumée dans le
menu de la semaine donc menu des tous
les jours vous êtes à l'institution
nutrition et des aliments fonctionnels
de l'université laval dans le complexe
en fait d'innovation aux créations
culinaires et alimentaire qu'est ce que
ça vous dit
menu de tous les jo ratés de faire c'est
donc dans un atelier aux créations
culinaires sont souhaite c'est réunir
des gens de l'entreprise et idéalement
de différents départements d'entreprise
pour qu'ils puissent avoir tous une vue
d'ensemble ont réuni après des
consommateurs le principe c'est vraiment
de faire participer
l'usager à toutes les étapes du
processus de création du produit
ces consommateurs gourmets sont au
centre de ce laboratoire vivant d'où
sortira des idées de produits à
commercialiser qui répondent aux besoins
des consommateurs
c'est des gens de news diverses séries
faut 10 et des pères des mères de
famille donc ça représente vraiment la
clientèle cible qu'on voulait avoir
inspiré de pratiques qui ont été
éprouvés en europe
les participants débuteront par un
atelier d'idéation l'âme damnée diw de
chances qu'on fait avec seulement
l'atelier débute par un remue-ménage
autour des produits à développer pour la
compagnie invité aujourd'hui les fumoir
grizzly l'entreprise désire développer
de nouveaux produits afin de répondre
aux besoins d'une famille qui ici c'est
la famille côté c'est l'avenir parce que
le prêt-à-manger là dans les épiceries
en a beaucoup beaucoup couper tout le
monde on est pressé aujourd'hui on va
voir des choses d'être fier est bonne sa
scène fait qu'en faisant des projets
comme on aujourd'hui on est capable de
mettre de l'avant justement des produits
avec ces critères log l'idée après cette
journée dédiée à sion l'entreprise place
des balises afin d'orienter le travail
des participants les un petit peu
réorganiser
à leur arrivée le lendemain on leur
demande de développer un produit surgelé
là le produit fini qu'on vous demande
d'imaginer cpo la quiche dans le rayon
c'est un produit de saumons qui va aider
le consommateur à faire une quiche à la
maison ils doivent tous y éliminer
certains ingrédients dans la préparation
alors sans fard noir on avait amené
certains allergènes
mais on voulait pas trop en mettre parce
que plus on met des des freins mais
l'imagination et plus freiner
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous êtes un fan c'est
comme un cube en fait de cuisine qui va
fondre avec une patte de saumon en
cuisine on laisse libre cours aux
expérimentations les plus folles nous en
fait un progrès l'objectif c'est que ce
soit amusant pour les enfants pour
manger du saumon mais appuyé de chefs
facilitateur on mettra laisser les idées
les plus éclatée et on réinventera
certains plats connus ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on fait intervenir
des gens qui vont être les usagers des
produits donc il est manipulé les
cuisines fait que ça nous permet de voir
en août comme entrepreneur comment ils
vont réagir en utilisant le produit pi
d'amener des correctifs tout de suite en
entreprise le développement de produits
alimentaires coûtent très cher et peut
prendre jusqu'à deux ans avant la mise
en tablette
la co création culinaire permet d'y
arriver plus rapidement le développement
d'un produit est beaucoup moins long vu
qu'on est directement avec l'usagé ça
nous permet de voir sur le marché est ce
que c'est un produit qui va être viable
est ce que c'est quelque chose que les
gens vont acheter et qui vont et met en
péril si mais malgré tout le prix en
vaut l'investissement parce qu'on voir
sortir d'ici avec environ 12 projets
possibles pour une bagatelle prix
vraiment pas énorme
lancé il ya un an avec l'aide financière
du gouvernement du québec le programme a
réalisé cinq projets avec des
entreprises de tailles très différentes
ça peut être de la grosse entreprise
qui veut vraiment alimenter fermant son
réservoir d'idées ou qui veut aller
valider des choses auprès du
consommateur comme de la petite ou
moyenne entreprise qui voudraient
s'adresser à un marché très spécifique
et puis ça peut aller également au
nouveau les entreprises en démarrage
est ce que vous trouvez ça réaliste ce
qui est en train de réaliser des
affaires un peu trop soins possibles
sous trop lent réaliser maintenant c'est
vraiment des trucs relativement simple
mais avec pas mal et leur touche
personnelle
les produits proposés sont variés
gaspacho salade de quinoa brochette tac
aux deux saumons effiloché ne sont que
quelques exemples la famille j'ai
beaucoup aimé le pogo ça permettait que
les enfants participent à l'élaboration
d'une main principale parce que ça s'est
vraiment produit intéressant pour une
famille de l'entreprise envisage que
dans la prochaine année elle pourra
probablement réaliser une ou deux
créations issues de l'atelier est
peut-être en direz vous d'autres dans
les comptoirs des supermarchés dans le
futur
[Musique]